we don't really have a Frank
conversation because we don't understand
the stratifications when it comes to
sort of race and identity and culture
and class and you they don't can't seem
to get their heads around the fact that
maybe these people think differently to
them because they're not interested they
genuinely don't care yeah I often say
that the most socially conservative
people in this country are ethnic
minorities but that's not a conversation
they're willing to have but you a white
woman are happy to say that it's not
real diversity because she doesn't think
the things that you think she should
think and that is so offensive on so
many levels but I think she this kind of
person goes to bed at night feeling good
about herself she thinks yep I've you
know I've put the world to write I'm now
at a point that if you have people like
that running the country every time you
see someone who's not white or male or
straight you know to some extent they're
A diversity higher and it's actually
damaging the mindset of these people I
never want to feel like a diversity
higher because it's so offensive I'd
rather just go back home I'd rather go
back home and struggle with everyone
else because that for me that's not
meritocracy that's that's an insult to
my hard work if you look at the single
motherhood rate in sort of black African
Community it's about 40 in Black
Caribbean communities about 62 that's
that's a 22 disparity I mean the single
motherhood rate in the Indian Community
is six percent right how many so
primarily indian-based gangs do you see
around the country I mean
yeah well yeah that's not the best thing
I just song every two minutes like you
just you don't see that I have a huge
respect for Indian and some South Asian
communities in this country because I
think they get it and I think sort of
even black African families that are you
know Christian or Muslim but keep their
family intact I don't think they
understand how much of a credit they are
to the society and how much really they
are holding Britain together
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm Constance
and kissing and this is the show for you
if you want honest conversations with
Fascinating People our brilliant guest
today is a writer broadcast and
political commentator Esther Quaker
welcome to trigonometry thank you for
having me yeah it's great to have you on
it's been a long time coming I know uh
we're big fans of of yours uh you do
great stuff for those people who don't
know who you are tell everybody who are
you how are you where you are what has
been your journey through life that
brings you to be sitting here talking to
us
um well I'm well I'm Esther I I'm a
writer and a broadcaster but I'm also
someone who makes a lot of noise on
Twitter that's right wasting me yeah
I'll get into these moments where I have
to I have to rant about something and
that gets me in a lot of trouble
um but I I moved to the UK when I was 14
from Ghana and it was mostly just for an
education
um I was here throughout secondary
school and University
um I studied politics and French at
University of Bristol and I just started
working after uni got a normal job but I
was always very politically conscious it
was something I was very passionate
about I debated all through school and
uni um so I was always the kind of
person that liked to sort of engage with
people intellectually and how I do what
I do now I got involved with a student
Grassroots organization called Turning
Point UK which is the UK version of
Turning Point us and it was very much
focused on kind of having some sort of
conservative outlet for students and
young people because I obviously you
know in higher education that's not
really a thing
um and so I started doing videos for
them I started doing interviews
um and I I just I felt like I had to be
part of a conversation because I noticed
things had shifted you know from when I
moved here in 2010 and I I never felt
like my my race was now a political
statement to to post brexit BLM all that
and I felt like wow being black is now I
have responsibilities yeah and I just
think this is very weird yeah right
because I have others but I'm trying to
live my life
um so but it was something I was very
passionate about I mean I I worked in
sales after school so I after uni so I
would you know be making something to 80
cool calls a day and then I'll just run
and go and do a turning point video or
do interviews so it was very much I was
never really in it to put anything other
than just pure passion and that kind of
snowballed so I thought I was tweeting
at the wall and then people started
paying attention uh but that's basically
how it happened
um I think one of the moments that I
realized things needed to sort of shift
was I was I had a friend at Uni that and
you know Bruce I was really proud of
getting to Bristol like when my mom
dropped me off she was like you know she
got three A's and I was like Mom you're
embarrassing me yeah but I wasn't I was
like really happy and I was like you
know what
I'm not aware that people back home
don't have the same opportunities that I
have so I have to work really hard here
and make something of myself because
I've been given the opportunity which in
and of itself is a blessing
um and I had a friend say to me don't
you get offended when people really ask
you where you're from and I'm like do I
look Welsh to anyone like who looks at
me and just thinks this girl is like
from the Scottish Highlands clearly my
ancestors come from a hot place
um but she she thought I should have
been offended and she was like you know
it must be really hard for you as a
black woman and I was like are you mad
do you know how much I've worked to get
here like what do you mean why would you
automatically assume I'm assuming it was
hard for you as well because you had to
study to get the grades to you know be
where you are I would never assume that
was difficult for you for whatever
reason right I just think you know she
just got down and got on with it um so
that kind of was one of my one of one of
my Awakening moments I became more
conscious to the fact that people
put certain things on me just because of
what they saw and I was like that's a
problem and what I'm
we have a really weird relationship with
race in this country yeah as someone who
came from Ghana at the age of 14 just
explained to me and explain to us in the
view and The Listener why it's weird in
this country because sometimes it's
difficult for us to grasp I think I mean
it's even weirder in the US every time
actually the most racist abuse I get are
from some black Americans just abusing
me just calling me all kinds of [ __ ]
and cool and I'm like wait what I don't
even know you know when we said you
could say anything
I think in this country uh it's we don't
really have a Frank conversation because
we don't understand the stratifications
when it comes to sort of race and
identity and culture and class and so
for instance I always have to point out
that sort of a black African
um is different from a black Caribbean
person and if you look at sort of
Statistics we've got with regard to
education housing all these sorts of
things you can see clear disparities
that that that should mean that you
don't you know group everyone together I
mean that I hate the term Bame right but
it should mean that if you're going to
have those conversations you should have
you know an honest conversation with the
facts right in front of you because I
think the people that try and engage in
these conversations the vast majority
really are not interested they're just
trying to Virtue signal and say oh but
you know you should acknowledge a black
person's lack of privilege or white
person or whatever and I just think it's
not that simple so when I moved here I
didn't really I mean I always say to the
credit of the UK I was very comfortable
I felt very welcome I never had any sort
of instances of racism or anything like
that and I I tell people that I don't
say that because I don't think there's
not racism in the world I say that as
someone who comes from a family that's
well traveled my dad's been to
Switzerland he's been to China they've
been to Malaysia my family's been all
over the place and they would say the
worst and sisters of racist there's no
face of places like China
we don't have those conversations
um so I I always say that you know the
UCO was very welcoming to me I really
appreciated having come here because I
met people that I wouldn't have
otherwise met
um and I was never made to feel like you
know it was an impediment it just they
just said get down get the work done and
you will succeed and that attitude's
changed around sort of 2016 2017 and I
was like this this is weird I don't
really like this because I actually had
a conversation with my friend yesterday
and she's she's mixed race but she looks
you know black
um and she was saying you know I'm doing
really well in my career but I'm
constantly like petrified that I'm A
diversity hire
and I've had so many conversations like
this with people you know from my
background and if you when you know
something about Africans is we just we
just want to work we just want the
opportunity to prove ourselves that's it
we're not obsessed with race and all of
that and that's not to say that you know
we don't know whether racism exists or
not but we we understand the difference
right we're coming from a place where
people can't even dream of the
opportunities we have we just want to
work and we just want to prove ourselves
and she was saying that because she has
that Obsession now when she sees someone
getting hired that's clearly A diversity
higher she's she's even harsher on them
she's like ma'am don't leave your house
with your Bonnet on for goodness sake
you know put on some clothes wear a
dress well you know because we're like
okay if this is going to be the case
then don't make us look ridiculous but I
don't even I don't think that's progress
because I was telling her I was like you
know I've I've had eye surgery before I
didn't really care that the person
performing eye surgery was a white man
or a Taiwanese woman I just wanted them
to do a good job and I think people that
push these sort of diversity courses and
all of that don't have real problems in
life because when you know it's [ __ ]
hits the fan you you don't care who's
sort of behind the the in the cockpit of
a plane that's about to crash right you
just want the best person that could
make sure you don't crash that's why I
really enjoy your common traster because
you know Francis obviously his
background his family being from
Venezuela me being first generation
immigrant and when I look at what you
say I don't think conservative or
left-wing or I just think you talk you
just say a lot of the things that most
people think that are quite common sense
yeah but you're allowed to say them in a
way most many people don't feel able to
this is the thing because you're a
person of global majority I'm a person
of color as opposed to what is the
opposite of a person of color person of
new color yeah I I just I anyway a
Gammon yeah or a beige I don't know
transparent
um but I get that and I it makes me
really sad because I'm like why are you
comfortable being neutered in your own
country but then I understand it as well
because you know when they have families
that depend on them they have jobs all
of that they don't want to sort of put
their foot in it but I find it really
funny that people call me conservative I
mean I am I'm conservative here and I'm
liberal in Ghana right which is
hilarious to me yeah like my parents
think oh you know she's just as normal
she's a bit you know Lefty I'm really
not like I'm so just I don't care
um but that's that's interesting that
because I I say things that most people
think it's just common sense I'm I'm
just a super conservative super right
wing and I I am conservative of some of
my views but I just don't think I I
think to attribute my social commentary
to just conservatism is weird because
most people I mean my friend I was
talking about she's pretty left-wing you
know she thinks exactly the same she got
she was at work um the other day and
they were like babe you know it's Black
History Month next month and she was
like oh for goodness sake and you know
she she was just like oh she expected it
right and it's like what now what do you
want from me uh but yeah are you tired
of using bulky old wallets giving you a
bulge where you don't want it to be my
old wallet was massive so it brought all
the ladies to the yard which was a huge
distraction and got in the way of my
esteemed work on trigonometry reg
wallets have an incredible solution for
you this is mine Sleek stylish and with
an industrial look to it it can fit 12
cards with cash on the back using a clip
like this one or a strap we've got one
for the whole team I've got one Francis
has one even our producer Anton has one
but he's from Liverpool so he flogged
his on the black market the great thing
about Ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee which means if you
want you can have only one on wallet for
the rest of your life reg are so
confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallet that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days today and that's not all for
every dollar you spent on the ridge
wallets website you'll be entered into a
competition to win a brand new upgraded
Ford Bronco or if you can't drive like
Francis then you can win 75 000 in cash
winners will be announced in October so
get spending because we're just such
great guys are going to give you 10 off
and free worldwide shipping and returns
to take advantage of this incredible
offer go to ridge.com forward slash
trigger that's ridge.com forward slash
trigger and use our special code which
is of course trigger
it's really interesting because there's
this perception in this country as well
that if you're an ethnic minority in
this country you're going to be liberal
and left yeah they can't seem to get
their head around the fact like my mom
who is South American you know Christian
conservative yeah
and you they don't can't seem to get
their heads around the fact that maybe
these people think differently to them
because they're not interested they
genuinely don't care yeah I often say
that the most socially conservative
people in this country are ethnic
minorities yes but that's not a
conversation they're willing to have no
question and you know I even I even this
is why I draw the difference between
black Africans and sort of black
Caribbeans because I say you know if you
look at the single motherhood rate in
sort of black African communities about
40 in Black Caribbean communities about
62 that's that's a 22 disparity if you
look at sort of cultural um sort of
norms in those communities they're
different if you look at education
entertainment you know a black African
tend to do better than black Caribbeans
there's so many differences within
communities even sort of Indian
communities to Bangladeshi to Pakistani
that if you really want to have that
conversation you need to acknowledge
those facts but people that you know are
not interested but just want a virtue
signal and show that they're good people
they're just sort of belt the same oh if
you're like a Joe Biden if you don't
vote for me you ain't black yeah and I
actually had this instance which really
really annoyed me and if you know me I
don't get angry easily at all I'm I'm
like you know I'm a puppy but I had this
lady that I've been on um a show with
before and she's lovely and I I didn't
attribute when I met her any malice to
her I didn't think and I don't attribute
any malice to anyone I have sort of
conversations or debates with because
maybe I'm naive but I don't think most
people want to blow up the Earth or
horrible
um but she said during the conservative
leadership race which unfortunately is
still going on
um that by the time this goes out it
will be over we already know who's gonna
yeah exactly yeah anyway but she she
said that
um she was talking about sort of kemi
badenark and all those people and she
said it's not real diversity if she's
using her power to oppress people some
some [ __ ] right and I was like why not
give me a good negro handbook then ma'am
and she was like you know that's not
what I meant I was like no no no no that
is so offensive it's not even funny
there are people in this country that
don't care what Kenny Biden looks like
but they want this woman to be prime
minister she's made it to the point
where she can even contest the
leadership that in and of itself is an
achievement but you a white woman are
happy to say that it's not real
diversity because she doesn't think the
things that you think she should think
and that is so offense on so many levels
but the thing she this kind of person
goes to bed at night feeling good about
herself she thinks yep I've you know
I've put the world to write and I'm just
like you complete cow how Dave and if
you know anything about sort of
Nigerians in particular they're very
they're very proud of themselves and
they work really hard they really and I
really admire them for that and I just
think someone her parents are probably
extremely proud of her because I think
she's worked really hard she's gotten to
the point of notoriety where people in
this country know of who she is and
admire her politics to the point that
they want her to leave this country and
you have this dumb cow and she is a
lovely lady but in that moment she was a
complete [ __ ] to saying that it's not
real diversity because she doesn't think
the things that you should think and you
have to really think about that there's
no way you can get around the fact that
that's just racist and horrible
um and that really that really really
did my head in because
I'm now at a point that if you have
people like that running the country
every time you see someone who's not
white or male or straight you know to
some extent they're A diversity higher
and it's actually damaging the mindset
of these people I never want to feel
like a diversity higher because it's so
offensive I'd rather just go back home
I'd rather go back home and struggle
with everyone else because that for me
that's not meritocracy that's that's an
insult to my hard work no I totally get
it and you bring up the the Tory
election thing and you know at least
trust is going to win yeah everybody
knows this
um and I was saying throughout when
Boris Johnson was having all his
different problems and party gay and he
said this and did this and did that and
whatever I was like I think he should
resign but I don't want him to and what
I meant by that is the stuff he had done
is the sort of stuff that a prime
minister should resign over cumulatively
but I always said you're not gonna get
somebody who's a better you've and
you've made that point I think you
turned you know you were critical of
Boris pretty early on yeah I think more
like sort of last year early last year
yeah but equally We've Ended up in a
position where I mean if the three
candidates were in the ballot I think
you'd probably go with Boris probably
yeah right I mean there there is a
section of the conservative party that
actually want him back because they just
think what's happened is ridiculous
um and I I've often said he's sort of
the victim of he is he's the architect
of his own demise yeah right because he
had everything he literally had
everything going but um one of who was
it um gov yeah he he was one of the few
people very early on that had noticed
boris's sort of Character defects and
said this is not the man you want to be
prime minister he's too big picture he's
not good with detail he's all over the
place and he will take himself down and
he saw it early on and for the
reputation that he gov got at in
Westminster for being a snake and not
loyal and stuff but he was spot on and
you never really hear people kind of
Defending Michael Gove because it's not
very fashionable but he was right
um and it's it's I I said from the
beginning boris's strategy was off
because one he surrounded himself with
sycophantic half wits and two he he
didn't he didn't have a real vision for
this country at the level of detail yeah
we'll get brexit died yeah level up what
the hell is level up where and you know
he the people that were supposed to get
that job done weren't sorry they were
not up to scratch I mean the fact that
Nadine Doris isn't our Capital will
forever be the biggest joke of British
history I mean it's ridiculous but he he
took himself down because he didn't
understand how politics works but I also
think it's a blessing in disguise
because I've long been very
disillusioned by our political system I
think that there are so many there's so
much wrong with the political party
system that we really need a bit more
diversity we don't know what the lib Dem
stand for so Ed Davey is a complete joke
the labor party I mean I understand what
Kirsten is trying to do now because he's
accepted he's never going to be this
with that big bombastic personality so
he's he's kind of going down a John
Major strategy and making the party more
palatable as as
opposed to him being a standout
character like Boris was and the
conservative party they're I think
trying and Reign it back and just focus
on their cool voters and the people they
can win and not really focus on like a
catch-all strategy which wouldn't work
and this is what happens when you
actually try and understand the nature
of politics you don't think people in
the red wall traditionally would vote
for Tory anyway so you're not going to
try and sort of appeal to them in that
way and it's just common sense politics
but I think we really need a change in
this country I think our political
system is a bit broken I think that a
lot of people especially young people
that just don't care anymore because
what's the point I mean two-thirds of
seats um seats in this country are safe
seats anyway so really if you wanted to
make a change how are you going to do it
and the party system is not the
mechanism to do it now I agree with you
the problem you're going to get though
is I don't think the party system will
change because the two major parties
have a a mistake yeah they have a vested
interest in keeping it that way and so
if we focus on where we are and what we
actually have you've got you've got rid
of Boris Johnson and you're going to
replace him with Liz truss yeah uh no I
mean no offense to list trust but but
you know I don't think that in the
Kremlin the the shaking in the boot you
know what I mean did you see that
I've got like Russian geography wrong I
just thought oh when she was foreign
secretary yes right anyway but I said
and actually I was about to do a show
and my dad texted me saying do you think
Rishi can become Prime Minister like uh
not no Dad why are you messaging me this
and he's like oh I think this trust is
ugly I don't want her to come back
to my prime minister she thinks she's a
minger that's not how this works
um but I you know what Liz trust needs
to accept a few things one I think the
first thing she needs to do is level
with this country she needs to give a
big speech where she levels look this
energy crisis not going away anytime
soon this is not a six-month problem
this is sort of at least a three to five
year problem well you're right and this
is sorry to interrupt just very quickly
uh we were watching back an interview we
did with Nigel farage earlier this year
that's what we do of our spare time
naturally yeah he's lovely actually he's
a really funny guys interview so he's a
great person to interview absolutely and
one other thing he was recorded me like
a week before the war in Ukraine I think
it was just as it was about to happen
and he was saying people don't know
what's coming and he was talking about
the energy bills this was before the war
in Ukraine so this attempt to pretend
that this is all about Ukraine complete
nonsense anyway no but it's true and I
mean there's a clip of um Trump going
viral when he warned that Germany's
um dependence on Russia Russian energy
is a problem and they were he was
laughed out of the room I was like well
he may be orange but he does say some
things that are on point sometimes
um what was I even saying yeah but let's
trust needs to level the country that's
the first so the energy crisis isn't
going away but it's not going away and
this is the thing she needs to be very
honest with this country and I know an
honest politician that's an you know
that's a paradox but it's true and she
also her team are core because one of
the biggest failings of Boris was his
team he didn't have anyone around him
that really kept him in check that were
honest with him that had the
capabilities that you needed to someone
like go should have been boris's right
hand man and I know that sounds weird
because he didn't even think he should
have been prime minister in the first
place but if he had the humility to
temper himself and not go down the Chris
witty route or you know silencing people
that had questions over lockdown and all
of that he would have still been here
with all his def with all his sort of
flaws so her team is also really
important in this trust but I also think
she needs to go back to the basics she's
from a very liberal wing of conservatism
so she's not the traditional I mean they
don't really talk about social
conservatism right it's not in fashion
you don't so you don't hear any
conservative politician other than Jacob
brucemore but that's because he has like
six kids you never really hear them
talking about you know get married stay
married have kids you know have a
traditional family structure gender
roles are not necessarily a bad thing
you know actual things that keep the
social fabric of this country together
you never really hear them talking about
it and I think actually that's a mistake
because you're you're probably going to
get a lot of votes from sort of
traditional Indian communities by doing
that because you're talking about things
that no one's talking about but that's
really fundamental to this country
um so that's I think that's kind of
where she needs to go she needs to move
she needs to have social conservatism on
the agenda but she also needs to have I
suppose a real commitment to actual
conservatism sort of fiscal discipline
we need to know what that looks like
because what I suspect is going to
happen is she's going to unveil the
largest sort of assistance package this
country's ever seen and my generation
people at least 25 and over 25 and
between 25 and 50 are going to be like
I'm gonna pay for this how exactly is
this going to work because I don't
really want to see my taxes going up and
if you act crazy I will move and that's
a problem as well because we're not
having enough kids and people my age
should be having kids should be having a
home to put the kids in and we're not
really we don't really see how that's
possible
um so I think she really has a big task
ahead of her I'm not going to set the
bar too high because I think that's a
problem we have in our politics we the
state has expanded so much that there's
so many things that comes under the
states agreement that you don't expect
them to do it properly but it's just
it's fodder for people to continually
whinge and [ __ ] and whine and it's like
look I don't really care what you
whether you think uh you know Pavements
should have rainbow Flags painted on
them but I would actually like for
burglary to be solved you know or for
people to stop stabbing each other
actually like basic policing of this
country to work you're right I see
you're a social concern
like I mean the solicitor Strikers in a
few days
um the criminal Barrister strike and I
just think this is a design right and
this is happening in a conservative
country that's been under conservative
leadership for 12 years how could you
possibly let this arm of of our justice
system fall to the point where you know
I think two since 2006 um criminal
barristers they've seen a 26 decrease in
real pay that is a disaster right
because these are people that are
defending the people that don't have the
means to defend themselves that's a
critical part of our judicial system and
they've just let that fall by the
wayside and I think this is this is
unimaginable and that's since 2006 so
we're talking sort of mid Blair era as
well this is not just something on the
conservatives but they've kind of seen
it and just kicked the the can down the
road so Esther and what does it mean to
you to be a conservative what does that
actually mean well it depends where I am
if if I was in the US I'd be like I'm
probably bang in the middle because I I
probably you know don't want to be
walking around with guns in Walmart
which I've seen but I'm also like not
obviously a leftist crazy I think being
a conservative means having some sort of
commitment to
a decent society and understanding what
makes a society work so I think when I
talk about conservatism I don't
necessarily just talk about Economic
Policy which I think I'm probably more
libertarian on than just strictly
conservative I I it's for me it's more
about family and social structure
because I think that's so important and
I don't think we talk about that enough
like I was having a conversation with
someone who was saying oh I can't get a
mortgage and I can't buy a home and I
said something crazy have you thought
about getting married he's like well why
would I do that it's like well it's two
incomes You Know Your Wagon is stitched
theirs they're legally obligated to like
you
that might be one solution but I just
think you know there are loads of single
people single young people that are
working in London are wondering how
they're going to get on the housing
market but that's really a very tangible
solution but there's so many mechanisms
that go around with that I find it
really funny funny fascinating the rise
of the red pill and the manosphere space
and stuff and I I look at it because I
was talking to my friend I was like babe
I grew up in Ghana I've had a front row
seat to these sort of intersectional
Dynamics since I was born
um but these are wait how did you mean
I mean anyone with common sense knows
that like a lot of the things that
they're saying is obviously true like
men liking younger women it's because
they're misogynist they're like look let
me tell you
let me tell you a conversation I had so
I was talking to this guy who's I think
he's a Mason he works he works my dad
and he's he's Muslim he's from the
northern part of Ghana and you were
saying oh you know
I'm looking for a second wife oh why is
the current wife do I said no you know I
just want to add the second one okay
cool what are your criteria it's like
you know I want someone she has to be at
least 13. and I wanted to have at least
just one child and I said oh okay why
it's like because I don't have that
money much money for her bride price so
he knows that he can't afford a premium
like 20 something hot single young
childless woman do you know what I mean
and but this is basic into sexual
Dynamics and he was like but she has to
be attractive she can't have a big
stomach he was telling me all his
criteria but I'm like the and the Red
Bull space talks about all these things
I'm like dude everyone knows this
everyone knows if you're younger hotter
um sort of more feminine you come from a
good family you'll know a headache to be
around and stuff like that really you're
and I can't believe how many videos that
are online where guys are effectively
learning how to be men off the internet
and then me and my brother are just
there like really so are you joking like
men having men wanting younger hotter
women or having more than like a side
chick or whatever and it's just like oh
no I'm like babe do you think as a
society we've just gone nuts when you
compare
I I'm really upset I get really upset
when I see like very intelligent people
talking about gender pronouns I'm not
gonna lie it really upsets me because I
just think Society is going to look back
20 years from now and think we should
have employed these Brilliant Minds to
something better like furthering
Humanity instead of going on talk shows
and arguing what the hell a woman is and
I call my dad it's like what's going on
there and I'm like they don't know
no one is it's crazy I'm like can I come
home this is absolute insanity and it's
just I I think we are really some
sacrificing Brilliant Minds at the altar
of this [ __ ]
that's it's an interesting point you
talk about gender roles and stuff like
that and I almost always agree with the
stuff that you say about it almost
always almost always yeah because you
make a tremendous amount of sense yet
here you are a confident young woman who
who earns a living who's not married as
far as I know right so so how how and
there'll be lots of other young women
like you some of them will be watching
this probably not many no not many but
we've seen the demographics really
what's the demographics well see this is
where I quite male and angry no okay no
it's nice that's such a [ __ ] idiot
baseball
unbelievable no the thing is I don't
trust online statistics because women
often don't want to identify themselves
online so but it's skews towards the
male side definitely YouTube YouTube
channel right but anyway so there'll be
other young women out there yeah I I
suspect there are out there right you're
sounding so much like a dad well I am a
dad mate yeah that's what I am who who
are in your position as well they they
want to have a career they want to make
a good living like all of that so isn't
hasn't the world changed the world has
changed but I think
you the way your personal life is yet
your mini Kingdom right I always said
that a home with a mother and father
kids it's a small Kingdom right a man's
house is his castle and I genuinely
believe that
um and I I look to my parents because
one there's no one I admire more than my
dad basically and I think I I think I
really hold a lot of um I think there's
a lot of value in wisdom of the past so
looking to previous generations and
seeing what they got right I don't I
don't necessarily think women being in
the workforce is a bad thing I think the
skill though which which was done really
stagnated wages and I think it was just
a benefit big corporations
um and I I do think that is a problem
but I I obviously always say I'm not
necessarily a career girl but I would
get bored just not doing anything else
other than just child care like I would
I would read and do stuff that
stimulated my mind but that's not
necessarily that doesn't mean that I
have sort of career Ambitions like I
want to be a CEO I'm not built for that
everyone who knows me knows Esther gets
really excited when she discovers a new
recipe she wants to try on you that is
my thing I love like cooking and taking
care of people
um and I just think I'm most women are
just built we were we flourish when we
have good healthy functioning
relationships I think that's what we
really want I don't think we necessarily
want to be most women don't necessarily
want to be CEO or have the stress of
this high-flying curse I'm sorry that I
can't do all that and look what that's
just too much
is too much work no I'm sorry but I
think you know the issue I think there's
a lot of the issues on both sides I
think men and women these days have a
lot of um they don't understand what
each other want and I don't think they
have the humility to look for it
um so I often say like with my ex I'll
be like what was it like being with me
and you know I I genuinely want to know
and they have nothing but positive stuff
to say so I don't sit there and freak
out and be like oh God I'm horrible I'm
crazy I'm it's just you know and I
talked to my dad as well I was like you
know it just hasn't happened yet and you
don't want to
who you marry especially in this day and
age where men and women don't need each
other in the economics and the strict
economic sense where like the man had to
go out and work and the woman had no
choice but to be married to him you you
form your bond and the nature of your
relationship evolves but that's not a
bad thing that's actually better because
you know people are choosing to stay
together as opposed to having no job no
no choice but to be coupled together my
dad also says choose someone expensive
so uh his his expensive expensive he was
like I don't bring a broke man to my
house
he's actually said that to me and my
brother it's just so um his analysis is
very interesting but I I just think it
takes a lot of humility on both sides
and kind of looking at yourself
objectively which most people can't do
um I often say surround yourself with
people that can be brutally honest with
you my friends Converse me for Filth and
they thoroughly enjoy it but I know it's
not coming from a place of malice or
from a place of just negativity or
jealousy
um and yeah I do think you know Dynamics
have changed but it's if you are
constantly working on being better and
surrounding yourself with better people
better caliber people you can't fail
it's impossible it's an interesting
point you made particularly at the
beginning of of that statement they
asked because I think what you're
hinting at really is something like my
wife is a big fan of John Gray who wrote
men from Mars Women Are from Venus and
we've had him on the show
um and one of the things that she sort
of learned over the time that we've been
together is there she can do many things
but there are certain things that make
her happy and certain things are done
yeah and I'm starting to see like we had
Louise Perry on the show to talk about
it she tweeted this clip today where
it's a it's like an actor I think
there's like a a pink or a blue head
woman from 2022 talking to her in the
1950s and telling her like what her
brilliant future life will be like yeah
and it's like you're gonna go to work
and do the home cooking and the cleaning
under the oh no and basically oh I think
not right and I I think quite a lot of
people particularly women are starting
to realize that this idea of having
everything
really wasn't at the same time at the
same time really wasn't what it was made
out to be yeah it's a scam we've been
scammed but this is the thing I think
again I see this is a uniquely Western
phenomenon because I think when I go to
other parts of the world we're just very
real with ourselves and we're just very
honest I don't have I mean if you look
at my friendship group all my friends
kind of are similar to me sort of
private educated they're not um they're
from all over the place Japanese Kenyan
Indian but our family structure our
family setup if you look at our lives
they look exactly the same right and
we're exactly the same kinds of people
in terms of um how we see our future my
one of my best friends she has three
degrees back from Warwick Bristol some
very educated you would see how as the
quintessentially career go oh no she's
happy to when she cooks for me she's
really happy she has this little white
puff dog you know she loves being a
relationship she loves taking care of
people it doesn't matter sort of how far
you go up the sort of Education
hierarchy or the attainment hierarchy
women fundamentally across the board
generally are the same right we value
our relationships more we value sort of
building with a man more and letting a
man lead in certain aspects my brother's
only three years younger than me when we
go out together this he just naturally
takes the lead and I'm technically his
older sister but I'm like you know what
do you want to have for dinner or I I we
just we just fall into this role because
I know he's more confident I know he's
Karma I know if any he's six foot if I
can't read something he'll just get it I
don't do any DIY I fundamentally refuse
I don't do any of that right and we
won't talk that we we grew up we grew up
in you know in Ghana and then we moved
here but it's just something that we've
naturally fallen into I always say when
I see someone a guy with his pronouns or
his bio or he says he's a feminist I'm
gonna buy I just know I'm just not
interested because I I'm not I'm not
the kind of woman I am will not fit you
would fundamentally I and I I often say
and my friends say this as well Leah
gets a lot of [ __ ] for saying this but I
don't want to be in a leadership
position in my relationship I don't I
just don't want to I don't care for it I
love being in a support rule because I
think I'm that's I'm best suited to do
that I would love to be a mother I love
sort of taking care of a home and I buy
fresh flowers for the house every week
it's ridiculous it's stupid you come and
see these bouquet in front of my house
but it makes me happy yeah and I love
that and I love how it you know
brightens a room and lifts the Ambiance
in a place I that's just how I am I
think and I think most women are built
that way that's why the beauty industry
is a trillion dollar industry right
Beauty and sort of appearance and
relationships and all these things
matter to us women a lot more than men
um why is it so controversial to say
that why is it why is it a lot of people
don't want to admit this particularly
women like if you were a man saying what
you just said you'd literally be Andrew
take yeah literally oh yeah I would be
yeah you know what I mean people ask me
what my opinion of him is I said oh yeah
he's great it's really nice and I know
people that know him and they've only
said positive things about him and I
just think I don't hang around with
idiots everyone I keep in my circle I
really respect and I really hold the
opinion in high regard and they're like
he's great he's lovely he's polite he's
you know I like but you know what I mean
the way societies because they're not
real with themselves this is the thing
and the people that have dominated the
conversation are people from a very sort
of narrow with a very narrow viewpoint
on this on this issue it's obvious it is
very obvious anyone even parents can
tell the difference between their son
and their daughter my room has been pink
since how I could remember everyone
comes into my room is like everything is
pink I'll get my mom decorated it the
curtains are paying the bed bed I only
have pink bed sheets the walls are pink
and there's always been I have princess
stickers even when I go home to Garner
they're still there Disney princess
stickers
um but it's but people people just don't
want to be real with themselves and I
think the conversation has been so taken
over by people of a very narrow
Viewpoint no no woman wants a feminate
man who doesn't like to lead no man
wants to feel like a [ __ ] in his own
home you know and even to this day and I
don't think it's oppressive right I'll
ask my mom oh can we do this and she's
like okay let me ask your dad that's
what the hierarchy looks like but he's
always worked she's always been the
support system she doesn't feel
oppressed my mom is nothing she's
definitely not a pushover and but but
the people that have dominated the
conversation like oh women don't want to
do this you know what women don't want
to do women don't want to work 60 hours
a week then come home have to take care
of the kids and then still have to sleep
with their husband at night we don't
want to do that I'm sorry I want to look
hot I want to
[ __ ] like my husband I want to have kids
I want to make sure my family and whom
my life and then everything extra is a
bonus it's a blessing I want to make
sure my community and my me and my
husband's kingdom is together before I
do all the extras and call myself a boss
[ __ ] or whatever but the police
isn't the problem though is that
that isn't really affordable for the
vast majority of women I think it is
um I think when you say affordable
device and like getting a house and kids
getting a house getting kids kids are
expensive housing is you see people have
made cases either that or the way I grew
up has influenced me a lot because if I
have a kid first of all you're eating
okay let me not let me let me imagine
how I don't think kids need to be
expensive right my in my my background
um you know it's very normal that when
you have kids after they grow to a
certain age you give the kids clothes to
your cousin who's just had a kid or
whatever in terms of you share resources
because it's a kid right I don't want to
see any Burberry tags on a kid's clothes
it's Primark Primark and poundland you
know really kids cost I think
maintenance wise should be as minimal as
possible because one they'll grow up to
they won't remember it and if you want
to spend anything on kids it should be
more experienced I should have married
us tonight
because my son is pretty expensive right
now I would wear I don't I mean I like
nice stuff I'm not gonna lie I would
wear like the nicer stuff and carry like
a three grand bag or whatever my kid is
wearing Primark to the day I can I will
attest to that because probably until a
couple of years ago I was wearing
Primark if my parents paid for it it was
either m s on sale or Primark and my mom
like you don't need anything else like
what do you fundamentally need we feed
you we clothe you your education is
important and you're doing well and we
encourage you but that is it but I think
also the structure the way my parents
structured the home is they are at the
top it's a pyramid if they and their
marriage is not solid if their kingdom
is not solid the kids will suffer yeah
they need to make sure that they're okay
their relationship is up top and then
the kids benefit from that structure it
doesn't have to come from money I mean
if my parents went and I don't want to
picture this because I'd make me want to
boil my eyes and bleach but they want
skinny to pick and Bora Bora I'm happy
for them now because I know that they
were doing it to keep the house together
because they're they're nourishing and
they're fortifying their marriage for
the benefit of everyone and not just us
the kids but the community at large the
small kingdoms within the big Kingdom
which is society and that's broken up
now because we don't really want to talk
about that we don't really want to talk
about what men want and I think men have
got a raw deal more than women why I
went on my brother because my brother
he's in a relationship now but I went on
his dating app and I was like
this is this is sad it's got one one
stuck two Stone overweight you have one
with blue hair someone's got a like a
bull ring yeah you know that thing they
use okay I don't know why that's a
fashion now but when I was a kid
the only cows had that thing in there
yeah I always have the same reaction
yeah I'm just like for what reason like
why my cousin had like put that [ __ ] in
your face like she's not allowed to wear
around me
um but I was looking at sort of the
girls going and I was like Wow and then
like 1920 you're beautiful you're
intelligent speak well you come from a
good home you're blessed you have food
on you you go to the fridge and there's
food in there right you're not starving
you live in a home you live in the UK
you live in the fifth most developed
country in the world be effervescent be
happy be light you know don't be a
raging [ __ ] constantly complaining
about microaggressions but I just think
you like why but I don't have that
necessarily much of a problem because
when I date older I'll be honest but
also I think men when they're clued up
they get clued up properly like they
know not to do certain things because
it's just unattractive and they have a
harder time so I think they have to
invest more in themselves to even
attract any women as opposed to women
that can be the complete wildebeest and
there's still someone that wants to
sleep with her
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably brand near like the
sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only Lee baroness
Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
Esther do you think we have a
fundamental problem in our society where
we don't where we're not honest with one
another yes and I think the people that
are monopolizing the conversation are um
they have too much power and I think
they they make it easy for uh people to
be
villainized right if that's the problem
what I'm saying now shouldn't be
controversial a lot of what annotate
says shouldn't be controversial a lot of
what people in my kind of my space I
suppose um conservative liberal but the
basics fundamentals about sort of
intersexual Dynamics it shouldn't be
controversial but you like we're out
here having like debates that news
articles saying um you know do parents
need to get married or should do do
children need to be with married parents
for the success of the home like well
yes but why do you even need to ask that
question but it's kind of trying to
normalize this idea that anything goes
right and the evidence is very clear
exactly on what the consequences are for
children growing up outside of family
home right or two parents what the
consequences are uh but we've got to a
point like like I think Francis is
getting there where being honest about
these issues is is like liable to get
you punished right now now we're not
just being dishonest we're lying yeah so
there will be that you have there's this
section online that really does my head
and they're like oh they became a
delinquent because they were poor and I
really fundamentally disagree with that
because I don't think being being
lower middle or whatever but not being
wealthy means that you're going to go
down a life of crime because I was like
well if that was the case and most of
the undeveloped well the developing
world would be ungovernable right in
Ghana for instance I feel very safe
right people are not very wealthy but
there's a family structure there because
there's an authority hierarchy you know
if you go and steal from someone and
someone finds out your dad is going to
whoop your ass like he will beat you up
and you'll be disciplined right that the
social fabric is such that you instill
morals in people without having it come
down to oh you know it's because it's
because that person is poor not the fact
that they didn't come from a two-parent
household with a solid Authority
structure that teaches them right from
wrong that is more valuable than
investing in the police frankly and it's
more valuable over generation see we
obviously have covered the issue of you
know absent fathers and and all of that
quite a bit but the way you put it there
is actually makes a tremendous amount of
sense which is
you know if you if you are able to guide
Society towards having more family
stability than the amount of money you
then end up having to spend on the
criminal justice system the police the
the prisons the they have to care all of
that it just it tanks and but this this
is the thing so I I often say that that
one of the reasons why I behave the way
I do in public and I carry myself the
way I do and my brother does is because
it's not just me I have a family that I
think why you're representing us do you
know what I mean I come from this home I
come from a home behave like you come
from a home like you were raised
properly so for instance I was like you
know I didn't go to Carnival because I
was uh doing some work but I was like if
I go to Carnival and someone tries to
bend me or then dagger me hell no ew why
am I gonna have a picture of me being
daggered we're all floating on the
internet my parents would kill me right
oh leaving my house in a bonnet dressing
gown and slippers that is that's not
it's not just the fact that I would feel
embarrassed but I'm like God my parents
invested so much to raise me in a
certain way and I'm going out there to
disgrace myself and embarrass myself and
it's the same with my brother he would
never go out in public I don't know
dressed like a hoodlum and think yeah
he's a bad man today because first of
all I wouldn't let him out of the house
and coffee
that is how you you keep a society
intact when people know that they come
from somewhere they have a
responsibility on their shoulder and
they the way that they behave matters
not just outside of themselves or the
immediate consequences but as part of a
bigger structure that's how you keep
things together not sort of investing
more on the police or telling people
everything anything goes be yourself but
also you know why has crime gone up well
we need to just pop more money into the
place there will never be enough police
officers to uh to kind of keep Society
in check and large part of that comes
from the home and how people are raised
and I think that's what makes the
difference it is look I was a former
teacher blah blah blah blah blah but you
saw the kids who had trouble with
focusing or concentrating or got in
trouble at school and you were like no
dad dad isn't at home dad's walked out
yeah it's it's very simple I mean the
single motherhood rate in the Indian
Community six percent right how many
sort of primarily indian-based gangs do
you see around the country I mean unless
they're About Accountants Yeah well yeah
that's unless the first thing out into
song every two minutes like you just you
don't see that I have a huge respect for
Indian and South Asian communities in
this country because I think they get it
and I think sort of even black African
families that are you know Christian or
Muslim but keep their family intact I
don't think they understand how much of
a credit they are to the society and how
much really they are holding Britain
together and Esther so I I think you're
making really good points sorry to
interrupt I just every time we have this
conversation what I wonder is how do we
change this how do we improve this how
do we make these things better now
obviously you making the point is
important you saying what you think is
important and that's why we wanted to
have you on because I think your voice
is valuable and so does Francis and so
do many of the people watching but what
are some of the steps that we can take
as a society to get us to an
understanding because this is one when
Francis asked you about conservatism
really I think at the core of what you
are talking about is
family family structure and an
appreciation that just because you may
not have a right in the second a super
logical explanation of why something's
worth for thousands of years maybe it's
not necessarily the right thing to throw
it out of the window yeah right so
that's where you're coming from but how
do we get more people and this is why I
come back to the housing crisis right
because
I agree with you I really do but I think
many people would recognize also that we
do have a situation where it's so
difficult for young people to pair up
yeah to get together to have kids I hear
you kids don't have to be expensive but
I think that's the first point the
pairing up bit Yeah that's what we need
so I think one is to be an example
yourself so I I think I'll feel like a
bit of hypocrite if I'm in my 40s and
like never married never had kids or
divorced or whatever I think what I I
place I think personal responsibility is
huge for me personally and I place a
huge responsibility on myself and how I
behave because I have to stick to the
morals and values that I espouse to show
people that it is possible so for me I
aspire to that sort of ideal of of
marriage and kids and and being a good
wife and staying together and all of
that and understanding that marriage is
always going to be easy I'll have to
lean on my parents a lot because I'm
like he left the toilet seat up again
you know I have to sort of I pray for
you that is the smallest thing oh my god
oh no yeah but you know lean on sort of
the established wisdom to be able to get
through my life so one is be an example
yourself you're going to talk about that
try and Inspire Aspire for that yourself
um but also I think we should normalize
uh certain Common Sense things like a
man typically doesn't want a woman
that's vulgar tatted up blue hair
overweight you know not feminine doesn't
have a certain it doesn't want kids all
these things we should normalize that
like you know saying telling people that
because they're not attracted to trans
women they're bigoted it's quite
ridiculous right we should normalize
traditional family values and
traditional rules and we should stop
shaming or making women feel like if
they don't want to have a massive career
if they want to stay home and take care
of their kids and they have to you know
struggle a little bit in the beginning
that that's fine well then not be a part
of you like you go I've had this
successful TV career I've been on all
these amazing shows like trigonometry no
like I've done all this cool stuff and
now I'm just a housewife I don't think
I'll ever be just the house I mean I
also pole dance
um so I'll be quite an interesting um oh
why but I do other things as well
because for me it's just feeling like
I'm being stimulated enough mentally and
physically um so I'll always find
another status stuff you're not bothered
about no I'm not bothered I mean to what
end like what does it do for me right as
far as I'm influencing people in the
right way and I'm being an inspiration I
think I'm doing my job I'm happy right
if I'm if I have kids and I'm taking
care of them and I'm in a happy marriage
and I'm an inspiration to people that's
me doing my job right and I think
everything else is just an extra and
it's a blessing but I think looking to
yourself and how you structure your life
is the first thing you can't you know
you can't put the world to rights if
your life is completely out of whack
that's ridiculous but I also think you
know pushing more socially conservative
politicians I think the fact that child
care is subsidized in terms of sort of
actual day cares but stay-at-home
mothers aren't it's a complete shambles
and I think that flies in the face of
everything we want to achieve and the
fact that it's a conservative government
that hasn't even appreciated this this
fact is is disheartening but that's on a
political level that's how I'd say we'd
get um to grips with that on a personal
level live your life as you say other
people should live their lives and and
have standards for yourself and a
societal level we need to just get real
we need to make male female Dynamics
traditional roles popular again and stop
you know when a woman says actually I
want to stay at home and raise kids or I
love cooking for my husband or whatever
let's stop demonizing her let's let's
praise her let's and let's have
let's do a bit more shaming let's let's
talk about that I I I absolutely believe
in shaming women that leave their houses
in a bonnet or you leave your house
what's up on it so it's a black girl
thing like you know it's kind of just to
keep your hair intact while you're
asleep you wear it at home yeah you know
it's something you wear in your house
your your what you were at home and what
you were into the public sends a message
right dress decently don't look like a
[ __ ] throw away your Crocs you know so
I'm I'm absolutely here for I believe in
shaming but I have the same standards
for men right dress well they're holes
in your trousers why you know speak
properly open the doors for women be a
gentleman because then she will treat
she will treat you like the lady she is
right and she will be kind and caring
towards you and feminine I think if you
live your life that way you are you are
sending a positive and Powerful message
um we need to do a bit more shaming
because and I don't really care but you
can see that from my Twitter feed the
fact that someone told me they're obese
because they're poor and I was like how
did you get the food if you're poor
but isn't there all so like with that I
mean there is a certain level like the
the food that you're going to be able to
afford is not high quality I don't like
that you don't I don't buy that and I
have a friend Ricky Gleason who did an
experiment on Twitter because he said he
was broke for most of his life and he
was also a heroin addict for most of his
young adult life and he's never been
overweight well I mean Harry does have
that effect it's an appetite suppression
the thing is he's never been in a
situation where he's had plenty or even
moderate months he's always been very
very poor and he he was like you know
you it's about the choices you make yes
fast processed food is cheap but so is
the basics that you need uh my brother's
always like why are there so many
sardines in this house like [ __ ]
because that's 40p yeah and it's very
healthy and it's very good for you and I
don't need to spend money on sort of
McDonald's which is five pounds when I
can buy 40p
um sardines buy some yams or potatoes
mash it together you know have some
sauce or something on the side and eat
it and be very happy I cook for myself I
I buy the bare minimum and I'm good
right I don't think necessarily because
you're poor you have to be I just think
it's and also exercise is free I the
reason why I I live the way that I do is
one because obviously I pull down you
have to be very fit and I'm always up
and down a pole and I always have to go
to osteopaths and Physio and all of that
but it's also because it's mind and body
if I'm fit and I know I'm taking care of
my body I I feel better yeah I'm more
positive I'm happier towards people I'm
more encouraging me taking care of
myself and me putting in the work to
improve minor aspects of my life is a
net positive on society because when
people meet me I try and make their day
better I try and and you know just make
them happier even if I make them smile
even if I tell a joke you know and
that's because I I'm in a the State of
Mind and Body to be able to have a
positive impact on society it's not just
the fact that people are obese right
it's a lot of those obese people are on
antidepressants a lot of those people
have negative sort of ideas of
themselves and the negative view of the
world it's a downhill it's a downward
slope and I I don't think people
understand how damaging it is yeah I
don't think they do so I want to come
back to what you said about uh child
care because it's a it's an interesting
point I think
um
about the Trap that we do find ourselves
in to some extent because uh from a
government perspective
subsidizing women to stay at home with
the kids from an economic perspective
would be suicidal absolutely terrible
idea and this is the Trap once you you
know rightly open up the workforce to
women
who want to work you've doubled the size
of the workforce and nearly stagnated
wages you you yeah of course it has a
massive effect on downward pressure on
wages but the economy is growing and the
economy must be growing but the economy
a lot of the metrics they use are vanity
metrics right they're talking about
trade and all of that and I'm like okay
it's trade but you're buying mostly from
other countries what are you actually
producing right right the UK doesn't
produce anything so this is what I'm
getting at right so because we have one
of our first interviews with an
economist called David pilling who
talked about how GDP is a completely
useless
economic well-being but my point is if
you encourage some of the socially
conservative policies that you are
talking about you are then taking women
out back out of the workforce and
suddenly the economy is not growing
anymore and we can't have that can we
estimate not necessarily you forced the
economy to change you forced the economy
to restructure you force the investment
to go where it needs to go you know you
can't have it just because the thing is
the jobs most women are doing are not
favorable jobs anyway most women don't
want to do the kind of jobs that are
doing now in a cubicle you know office
administrator or whatever right so it's
not like you're taking away high-flying
jobs in the first place but also I think
that it's a societal benefit right it's
not like the money is going you need to
conjure the money up move the money from
Child Care from these sort of child care
institutions to stay-at-home parents
because you're fortifying the society's
social structure it's a better for the
kids to actually live in that sort of
environment where they have a primary
caregiver and they have that attention
but they're also sort of going to be
around other kids and all of that but
also it forces the the economy to
restructure and that's what we need I
mean I've said since the 1970s around
most western economies have atrophied
right people say like sort of trump
Trump's rise was the fact that he said
we're going to get all the jobs back
from China actually moving production
eastwards is what saved a lot of the
jobs in Western countries because no
because that's the truth because these
economies were atrophying in the 60s and
70s we weren't investing in the right
places I said the UK doesn't produce
anything but we have the second largest
Services industry only you know second
to the US right these are things we need
to invest in we need to invest in high
growth high-tech Industries where it
doesn't it's not because women are not
there doing the menial jobs they don't
want to do anyway that you know the
society is tanking or the economy is
crumbling or whatever that's that's a
myth that's a fallacy and also a lot of
the the metrics that they use to to
measure growth and success they're
vanity metrics right is your Society a
success when society when you know homes
are crumbling when people kids are not
growing up in two two-pound homes is
your Society success when you know crime
rates are through the roof because
people haven't been taught proper
discipline at home they haven't received
a backhand ever no I'm serious that's
the thing these are these are vanity
metrics that they're using because at
the end of the day it benefits multi
multi-national corporations that's
that's that's the long and short of it
it doesn't benefit anyone for women to
be out of the home and not taking care
of their families for this for family
structures to to be crumbling and the
perfect example is the Indian Community
in this country right it's a perfect
example and I I just I don't understand
why we've fallen into this we bought
this lie that you you have to
um keep things as a status cross
everything will come crumbling down no
you have to force change you have to
force Innovation it's the same argument
I say with the EU you know there's no
such thing as free trade in the EU the
EU is the largest protectionist block on
the planet right and because of that a
lot of companies it stagnated a lot of
companies ability to invest in
Innovation and to improve and to compete
on the world stage because they don't
really need to compete on the world
stage they have this closed Market of
people with a certain level of income
that can buy their goods and services
they get the cheap sort of raw materials
from China or the East and then they
just keep ticking along and I'm like
that's not how you grow that's not
proper progress right stagnation so I
think it's a complete fallacy it's it's
such a good point because it does feel
now like we're working against our own
self-interest and if you look at a lot
of people's lives they would say that
they're not happy they're not fulfilled
and they're doing something simply
because they have to do it I mean and
I'm really happy one thing I am I
optimistic about is the rise of the
monastery of space to an extent I mean a
bunch of con artists there but I think
the fact that we're even having real
conversations about what men are really
men and women really want at least
that's a guide in the right direction so
if you think right I'm not going to buy
the [ __ ] that I've been told about
being a boss babe or you know a guy that
sleeps his way what is a box pipe I'm
carrying on this is crap on Instagram I
keep saying it I'm a boss babe I'm hey
leave me alone I don't want to hear that
crap like I don't need to prove myself
to anyone but it's part of this idea
like Hollywood movies where exactly like
a a five foot five foot five woman just
like destroys 10 massive guys in a fist
fight I'm gonna get to that actually
because I watched a film from Netflix
and it's actually it's traumatized
well the thing is the fact that we're
having this conversation about what men
and women really want that's a step in
the right direction yeah because if you
choose if you have that information and
you choose to ignore and you still
choose to go on in the way that you you
want to find but I think by 2030 women
half of women over 30 are going to be
single and unmarried so it's it's going
downhill pretty fast and I I don't know
if I'm allowed to say this but men that
are cleared up and are realizing
realizing this are not going for those
kinds of women no and I I've actually I
don't know if I'm allowed to say this in
my experience I've had loads of guys
saying oh I actually don't date white
British women because the family values
are out of work they're not feminine
they don't stay feminine for very long
they just fit for like five ten years
and then it goes downhill and stuff like
that so I have people say oh you know I
want a traditional African woman I'm
like what exactly do you mean
because are you going to call me your
chocolate Beyonce because I've had that
I've had that in France and I'm like not
not here for it again you know I think
the fact that we're having those
conversations are a step in the right
direction also Hollywood is to blame
yeah yeah Hollywood is to blame when I
see these miniature women that are like
five foot five and I'm five foot five I
live in heels because I'm so short and
this I see them in the superhero films
like they're beating up these man or
their boss baby I just think but why
because it's a lie I couldn't I
literally couldn't beat up anything why
why have you and this these films that
come out and they're just glorifying
promiscuity and these women just acting
really unfeminine and I I watched this
film the other day which is I've look my
my I know I have a bad taste in films I
enjoy Fast and Furious and romantic
comedies I like my entertainment low IQ
so really anything Netflix puts out
shouldn't be that bad this was the worst
film I'd ever seen and it's because
within 10 minutes of watching it this
girl this young girl nice waitress was
accusing this guy of casual misogyny I
was like okay well you set the standard
there and then halfway through the film
it's like it zooms out of her flat and
they're full flags hanging out of her
flat and this one is a BLM flag one is
an LGBT flag one another [ __ ] flag
and I just think they're not even subtle
with the messaging so they really want
you to know that they don't approve of
certain Lifestyles and they want you to
Aspire to be that boss babe and that if
you don't have a sort of a certain image
or Persona you're dull and I'm like I
don't think anyone would ever meet me
and think I'm dull right and I don't
have to prove myself to anyone in terms
of how intelligent I am but I want to
take care of a man right I want to take
care of my family I'm a really good cook
I come from and I'm basically like my
mother right my mother never she
wouldn't even let me leave the house
dressed a certain way she I've never
seen her look raggedy my mom came to a
parent-teacher meeting when I was in
school here and someone's like oh your
mother's such a diva I'm like no she
she's a woman
[Laughter]
[Music]
and I'm so grateful that I've been
insulated in that way because now I see
like I swipe through my brother's dating
I was like who he's like why are you
swiping left and all them like because
they're awful and I would never let you
bring any of them to this house
it's it's a funny point you make about
um the manosphere and how men who are
clued up on doing that people are often
saying to me well you've just had a baby
boy it's not a good time to to be a man
is it and I'm like it's a [ __ ] great
time to be a man as long as you
recognize the [ __ ] and ignore it
right exactly and if you are prepared to
remain a man while all of this is
happening there are plenty of women out
there who are also not into the [ __ ]
yeah and part of it is that you know at
a basic level you can change the the
software but the hardware is the same
and it's been there for thousands tens
of thousands of years it's not going
anywhere you can try to change the
software you can put all the crappy
updates in there that you want the hard
way is the hardware and at the end of
the day most women eventually want a man
to settle down with to have kids with
they may want to work or not that's a
different issue but like if at least do
something they enjoy right not like sort
of office administration and but I also
think you know and when I I'll probably
touch on the point of humility right
because other than the humility to know
what each other wants also the humility
to be honest with yourself like I think
a lot of women have really really high
standards and I say this as like a
self-identified princess like my dad
calls me hello princess like Daddy and I
know this about myself but I also think
I don't think it's reason like every
everything is they're trade-offs
everything is a trade-off right you
might want a guy who's established and
older and Rich but you know he comes
with a lot of baggage because to get
that established and You Know Rich and
whatever you know he's had to deal with
a lot his patient was worse then he kind
of wants a woman that looks a certain
way if you're not in the age bracket
that he wants too bad maybe you waited
too long just get real with yourself
just be honest and it's fine because at
the end of the day what you're looking
for is a stability and to build
something that really matters not going
for this glossy kind of Ken perfect
Kendall that you can Flash to the world
I don't think that really matters and
that's someone my dad is my dad is very
successful but he's really had to grind
whenever I tell him about like oh I went
on a date with this guy he'd be like is
he focused he doesn't ask me what car
did he bring or what how did he dress
with he obviously he doesn't want some
Hobbit in his house but the point is you
just say is he focused because he knows
that's something that I can work with
because he knows me exactly he was like
look cookware you're very intelligent
you're very feminine you're very oldest
but you need someone that is on that
wavelength because if you if you want to
build with a man like that you need a
man who's looking for that woman to
build with you can't you can't put a
sort of square peg in a round hole it
doesn't fit it needs it just needs to go
together focus is such an attractive
quality in a man particularly because
that's that's the currency of of
masculinity is doing drive and focus and
discipline and consistency and I think
one of the things I I mean I when I was
um one of my ex used to say you never
bother me and I was like why it's like
I've been quiet for this I'm like well
I'm assuming you're working you're doing
something busy and he's like why do you
think like that I was like because
that's what my dad does right I don't
always spend time with my dad I haven't
seen my dad since December 2020 because
of the pandemic but I know he's he's
working and then he'll send me messages
of a project he's finished and I'm like
yay my daddy support you know and I I
praise him and he knows I'm very very
proud of him but he also knows that he's
raised me to know that the kind of man
you want it's not going to be sitting
around always having time for you he
does not going to message you 24 7. you
need to be on Eastern stand that you
need to be able to keep yourself busy
that's why I'm the kind of person that
loves to learn new things and always do
things I'm crazy enough to be spinning
on a pole in my underwear but it's fun
for me and I'm it's a net positive for
everyone because I'm taking care of
myself to the best of my ability to know
that I'm enough for you and I can be
what you need and also on societal level
as well I'm a positive influence and I
think everyone should have that mindset
you need to have strict standards with
yourself yeah completely agree but
Esther it's been an absolute poster
thank you so much for coming in uh the
last question we always ask is before
our locals before our locals questions
uh is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be and obviously the
question is uh who makes a better job
off rice Nigeria
you don't need to ask it's obviously
gone in
um and I say this as a fantastic book I
I actually taught my Nigerian X how to
cook jollof so yeah he's accepted it
really yes you I I told him at Uni and
well I used to make it and he's like can
you show me in case you dumped me I was
like okay
um and I showed him he was like no it's
legit I actually probably taught him how
to cook properly
um and then she dumped him anyway yeah
oh he had to go back home um but one of
the things I see it sounds better
because you saying that than me saying
that yeah to go back home yeah I know he
pissed off his dad no I never slag off
that's another thing a woman or anyone
that slags with their exes run
um because there's no personal
responsibility there you chose them
um I think one thing we're not talking
about enough that we should be talking
about is probably abortion I know that's
really heavy but I I really I really
really hate the attitude that we have
towards it like it's just a black or
white issue I watched this comedian I
don't remember who was but she was like
it's my body my child's like no at that
point it's sure it's not your body it's
an apartment right and you're sharing
with the co-tenant which I thought was
really funny but I I think regardless of
what side you lean on I don't like this
idea that we
make it not a moral issue it's clearly a
moral issue right because what's going
inside you is not a chair
but at the same time as well there are
circumstances like a woman being raped
or being underage that's like well you
know it's it's really sad but that that
line is very dividing and I think the
fact that contraception is free and
readily available in the UK and one in
four pregnancies are aborted by young
women that really 50 years ago would
have been married in a family and having
those children I think it's a huge
blight in society and I think when we're
at the point now where people are really
just not having kids because they can't
afford a home or all the basic things I
think it's it's it's suicidal that we're
not really having constructive
conversations about that because there's
so many issues that I have around how we
talk about abortion and I admire the
Americans as passionate as they are for
at least recognizing that it's a moral
issue at least in the Middle Ground not
On The Fringe ends where there's like
it's just a polyp or you know it's
murder on the other side you know what I
mean we've had great conversations on
this show with uh Anne faradi and Dr
Callum Miller from the post Pro and uh
anti-side but I think actually it comes
back to the very good point that you
made early in this conversation which is
I actually don't know that we would need
to talk abortion quite as much as I
think we do need to talk about it now if
some of the family stuff that you were
talking about earlier was in a different
place yeah absolutely and just I I think
that's one of the biggest problems that
we face I don't think people understand
and I I don't know to be honest I don't
know the extent to which my profile is
going to grow or to the extent to which
my voice regarding societal issues in
this in this country will grow enough
but if it does and I'm really hoping I'm
blessed it will that's something I
really really want to talk about but I
also want to reflect that in my own life
I don't want to just be that kind of
person that's harping on about it one
I've seen it I've grown up in that found
I've seen the benefits of it but also I
want my life to imitate that and I want
people to see that as possible and I
just want men and women to be better
particularly
um women because I think we've been fed
so many lies
well a great note to end on Esther thank
you so much for coming on the show
really pleasure to chat with you a
really great pleasure to chat with you
uh we're going to ask you a couple of
questions from our locals but in the
meantime where can people find you and
follow your work if you dare on Twitter
if you're if you're bored enough um SDK
underscore K I'm on Twitter I do a lot
of work for talk so you can see me on
please Morgan's show on censored who's
Morgan uncensored or the talk which is a
panel show on talk TV
um but I also do I also write for the
Daily Mail on The Daily Express as well
so all over fantastic thanks for coming
on thank you for watching and listening
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one or all
show all of them go out at 7pm UK time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
and I have a lot to say about kind of um
the dinghies and people that are coming
across Channel numbers because I
actually and I say I have a really
personal experience with someone who um
did that trip across the Mediterranean
but he's in Italy now well Esther I know
we've got to local questions but this is
really interesting if you've got time
yeah tell us about that
[Music]